what's better spider pool or dead
spiders minor pool sounds less dumb dead
spider [ __ ] - I'm composite deadpool
and spiderman and then he cuts off miles
his head that book was [ __ ] up I'm
sorry no wait I didn't get to look at
the combo but okay I don't even know
what my folks are I forgot immediately
what all those combos were so I'm just
guessing no okay what uh-huh you beat me
with it so it didn't go into the rest of
it
hahaha going to commit suicide oh I got
you okay they do it can I do it dammit I
didn't know what was gonna happen is our
fan base officially called the bomb
squad now yeah sure why not no God you
just getting there the bro party at the
bomb squad avoiding that question so
hard oh you played his [ __ ] destro
what do you want me to do do you want me
to play the person I suck at yes you
have I want a single round of injustice
so far yeah last maybe I'll win if I'm
the most powerful character in existence
hey we can play that do we holy cow
that's great we hang on we gotta figure
this out there's a brief adjustment
period every time we turn on anymore
goddammit you keep winning stop waiting
Josh I must Slav I will do keek bane
just love squad on truth truth look yeah
I mean your brother
yeah come on by the time I unpause it'll
be too late to do a fatality oh damn it
I didn't do the color ah was it up or
down at the very end of that combo I
think I [ __ ] in a balloon [ __ ] who
should we play us now oh I'll play is
the most American man he's super
muscular and he's got robot arms look at
him look at that guy
you look at that guy and you just shout
America
are you holy [ __ ] are we doing the okay
I'm so down for the ladder okay it just
Auto selected the ladder
oh [ __ ] I'm doing Hurst I guess so I
mean what would I be doing you walk I
was not ready for them shoes Jax is so
cool look Jack do metal arms what's cool
about that new cables a [ __ ] he's only
got one metal arm look at me I got to do
you think about the doctor do movie
I think Doctor Doom has potential be
cool but I just kind of don't know who
the villain would be for it because a
movie needs to have conflict I can see
it as being one of those movies that you
hear about that never gets like actually
made but they talk about doing for like
four years like gambit what do you spare
my ps4
why do you think they stopped having
smoke in these games just because it
what do you think it had something to do
with like is the loss of popularity of
cigarettes like do you think like some
concerned parent was like look at this
character encouraging kids to smoke
we're super cool tell officer green
explode if I pull out my phone is there
like a V I've got a question for you our
traps gay I don't know if I'm
necessarily qualified to answer this
question you know why are you asking is
it because I'm wearing a dress right now
is that why you're asking me this I'm
asking you this question they can't see
they don't know I could put on my moon
night Class A and that could be
addressed I could I'm wearing a kilt um
I'm a Nazi mad uh no you loved having a
fit yeah you're like you know if you
think that the white race is much better
than whatever race you know that's on
you man that's on you I got your opinion
listen I honestly have no way of arguing
back so it's our only gave you know it's
a guy you know what no traps it's got
just because they have a dress on
doesn't mean they don't have a dick this
is happening the children watching this
it's [ __ ] grow I know hey you're
totally not wrong about that there's a
bunch of middle schoolers I'm pretty
sure - it's a my plane - I know without
you even noticing because I know you
hate this one going for like three hours
they probably don't even notice what
we're playing this has been going on for
three hours I'm as surprised as you are
uh Mendoza how was Turkey Khan again
Turkey Khan was has that happened yet
did that happen it's spider-man ps4 so
I'm super glad this game doesn't give a
[ __ ] about collateral damage because
we're doing like Man of Steel levels of
destruction like look at this I'm not
even fighting the ants I'm just blowing
up buildings
I haven't give a [ __ ] I'll help them I'm
on their side now cratering what the
hell does the reverser do that's also a
word I made up I've betrayed you you
killed me
why you mention I've become one with the
ants I am now on their side
I will help them destroy the earth okay
I'll start by defiling your corpse with
my bouncy bullets low oh we're both dead
that's - I landed in the bathroom I just
look really upset someone screencap that
dude I choose the worst one has like
nine minutes your is disappointing is my
son reasons because I need to okay let's
just I need to uh huh
I can't handle any more on this game we
just played this so he could get our
asses kicked cuz this games hard Hey
look I got a hundred percent completion
in this game actually have all the
achievements in this one mad at you for
replacing me I'm gonna shoot you so
Batman love me again
I'm daddy issues the super ho
no I'm gonna be Mysterio that's not what
I know look now I'm Deathstroke and
gonna kick your ass Teen Titans season 5
got dark whoa turn into a aminal yeah I
just pressed cool I'm trying to think of
like five things at once Oh composite
Batman Superman remember that yeah so
cool cyborg superman look I'm look
Superman cyborg there's a giant woman
exploding the moon you have to stop her
how long does this stream have left you
have no idea we recently probably think
muttered ops we should probably end its
you know love that noise there's a lot
of people saying they're dying I'm so
turned on are you guys still going ha ha
ha I know I want to quit I feel like
this has gone on too long and stop being
funny no it's okay for a lot I think I'm
just flying around the moon like an
[ __ ] okay done I know we're just Tom
Ennis
okay
yes see you guys see ya we love all of
you thank you for donations we
appreciate them all of them are going to
more videos and more stuff and probably
food because I need that thank you
you're all awesome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]